j julie julie oui
catastrophe tel n'est pas là haut
françois un bon jour que zimbo mais
c'est à froid ohrid
catastrophique giuly n'est pas là oui je
le sais mais mais pourquoi ce qui est
spécifique casimir casimir d'une
inquiète il s'est passé quelque chose de
coin j'ai faim ouf le v10 dont tu meures
et fait peur mais c'est très grave j'ai
très faim je voulais lui que lui acheter
pour ce qu'il faut pour faire un rat
super gloubiboulga gyan on va dire
justement ça me fait penser que
plusieurs d'entre vous m'ont demandé la
recette du newbie boulga ah oui moi
aussi j'ai reçu beaucoup de lettres à ce
sujet alors casimir dur profite pour
donner la recette ah bon
voilà écoutez moi bien vous prenez un
grand bol vous mettez dedans du chocolat
en poudre a une grosse part
vous ensuite à de la confiture de
fraises une grosse part aussi
une grosse part de banane écrasée
de la moutarde et de la saucisse de
toulouse
tiède mais cru eu une grosse part un
aussi vous mélangez bien le tout vous
écraser et puis vous mangez c'est très
bon vous essayez si vous voulez mais je
vous préviens je n'ai jamais vu personne
en dehors de casimir et mais le
gloubiboulga
quand je vous lis pas je l'attendais oui
avec beaucoup d'impatience ou pourquoi
parce que j'ai très faim je voulais
acheter tout ce qu'il faut pour faire un
gros rhume yoga regarde j beaucoup mieux
oridion c'est vraiment un beau gâteau
c'est pour moi c'est pour nous c'est
vraiment une excellente idée ah oui tu
devrait rajouter quelques un choix et
des cornichons des anchois et des
cornichons la crème chantilly aux
battues en mettra sur ton morceau si tu
veux mais moi j'ai pas envie de gâcher
mon gâteau quand on le mange ton il me
met l'eau à la bouche ida maintenant si
vous voulez alors on veut on veut bon et
bien suivez moi qu'est ce que je vais te
couper il est vraiment beau
on va se régaler casimir
qui veut mon premier morceau mois au
point pour atteindre qu emploie la
méthode des casimir hulse je la connais
pas qu'est ce que c'est de cette
audience m je les donne une part à
chacun et le dernier pour le morceau qui
reste la bombe adoptons la formule
comores alors attends je réfléchis c'est
un peu voilà si je prends mais seul le
premier morceau j'aurai un petit morceau
si j'attends françois va avoir un
premier morceau petit jules y aura un
deuxième morceau encore plus petit et
moi j'aurai le troisième et dernier très
gros morceau d'accord puis j'en
apprendrai le dernier morceau le dernier
morceau ah bon tu écoutes françois voilà
ton morceau merci je n'en attends rien
les assiettes aussi les enfants vous
venez manger le gâteau mais non c'était
pas prévu mais nous les noirs les
enfants ce gâteau et wagons très très
bien mais nous ne venait pas il est pas
bon du tout on n'allait pas manger sai
il n'y a même pas de cornichons et
d'anchois avec un maître les dégoûter
casimir vous n'allez pas moins enviable
c'est très mauvais tiens c'est comment
tu vas pas manger ton sac au sol casimir
attendait une assiette
avec les as et il est bon en
fait dit don cameron pour ce petit
morceau je suis désolé je me suis trompé
dans mes calculs il nous reste que ce
petit morceau pour nous deux oh
j'aurais mieux fait de prendre le
premier morceau est bien comme ça
quasiment dû te souviendras du proverbe
un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu n'aura
fait que casimir ne désespère pas je
vais te préparer un go gloubiboulga et
puis l'année prochaine où sera plein de
gâteau qu'on mangera les vrais sa
gazinière du n'est pas au courant moi on
me dit jamais rien et bien l'année
prochaine nous allons avoir notre propre
champ de blé avec des épis et des
graines au bout bien sûr regarde là y
ait un stack de blé pour semer et
l'année prochaine on aura des dizaines
de vitamines et
des dizaines de sacs de blé pour faire
des centaines de bons gâteaux
encore un petit effort et j'aurais voulu
tout le blé pour faire de la bonne
farine avec cette farine je vais faire
un délicieux gâteau je mettrai dedans
des anchois des piments du caramel de
chocolat ça va être délicieux
et puis franchement on va être très
content parce que j'ai suivi ses bons
conseils ça va quasiment rabia françois
tu vas être très content dis donc qu'est
ce que tu fais là eh bien je suis vite
et conseils mais quels conseils à ap un
tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras et
du fait ça avec le blick que l'on devait
se met dans notre chambre est bien sûr
tu vas être content mon dauphin quasi
millions l'année prochaine nous n'aurons
pas de réponse non mais comme dit le
proverbe
un tiens voilà un bon gâteau vaut mieux
que tournera sur l'année prochaine
[Musique]
montrez votre poisson franck et georges
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une anguille
très pas que ça ressemble un peu un
petit serpent c'est bon à l'anguille
et toi jean
une seule montre ça très très bien oui
là la forme val plat très bien mais tu
continues
et par ici
est-ce que différents qu un saumon
quelques couleurs à saumos leur rose
c'est ce qui fait le saumon pour les
pauvres ils remontent le fleuve
et toi christophe qu'est ce que tu fais
à une truite
qu'est ce que tu peux me dire sur la
truite
un peu sans qu'ils disent à tous qui
sera pide et puis la rivière très bien
et bien moi je me souviens au cours d'un
de mes voyages dans un petit village et
j'ai mangé une truite aux bleus
excellente écoute casimir j'aimerais que
tu dessines les poissons pour leur
beauté et nous pas dans l'espoir de les
retrouver dans ton assiette il ya des
moments françois où je me demande si tu
m'aimes vraiment tu me fais toujours des
reproches
aujourd'hui les lignes rebelles
je vous avais tout sabine et ce sans
même vous voulez bien pardon tu penses
ce formidable qu'est ce qu'il y aura à
manger casimir casimir quand on est
invité à dîner chez quelqu'un on ne
demande pas ce qui rend menus c'est très
mal élevé ah bon ah oui parce que les
gens pensent que l'on accepte uniquement
pour leur part exactement je suis ravi
que j'ai compris julie de toute façon
j'accepte pour l'invitation mais qu'est
ce qu'il y aura à manger casimir tu
vraiment incorrigible ce n'est pas grave
écoute je vais essayer une nouvelle
recette le gloubiboulga au moins comme
ça non ma nouvelle recette je crois que
tout le monde n'aimera pour la salade de
pois pour salah de poissons et bien tu
vois françois il n'y a pas que moi qui
aime manger du poisson ça casimir toi
quand il s'agit de manger plus rien
d'autre n'existe de toute façon je n'ai
plus envie de faire le dessin je préfère
rejoindre julie et ben vas-y
montre ton dessin gérard
qu'est ce que c'est ça un brochet il est
beau c'est un poisson d'eau salée ou
d'eau douce douce et dans les rivières
la boisson très voraces sa land de
poisson pour confectionner une
excellente salade de poisson il faut se
procurer de l'huile du sel du poivre du
citron des oignons quelques tomates 1
poivron des champignons tu commences ta
salade spéculer der garde j'ai tout ce
qu'il me faut sauf le poisson que le
pêcheur va apporter et il vient bientôt
oui il faut patienter bonjour tout le
monde salue en retard c'est seulement
vous bon tu n'as pas l'air content de me
voir signer un chacun ya quelqu'un
d'autre ne vous inquiétez pas d'acteurs
qui provient que dire de lui faire une
salade de poisson dès l'arrivée du
pêcheur mon dieu heureusement que vous
m'en parler j'allais oublier de vous
prévenir la gêne mauvaise nouvelle le
fils du pêcheur csc s'est déchiré et il
n'a pas pu pêcher vos poissons et il m'a
demandé de vous prévenir
c'est que l'épouvantable catastrophe je
suis sincèrement désolée qu'elle génère
bon ben il faut que je continue ma
tournée mais je repasserai tout à
l'heure à l'est à tout à l'heure
françois
casimir tu vois mon invitation est
fichue faire une salade de poisson sans
poisson c'est pas possible c'est
vraiment très très ennuyeux le filet du
pêcheur est déchiré il n'a rien pu
attraper ah oui c'est à dire qu'il n'y a
plus d'invitation à dîner c'est pas
grave je vais faire une promenade avec
les enfants et moi ça te remontera le
moral on est les enfants sylvain d'idées
tu viens qu'à venir non je préfère
rester à bord comme de l'autre on y va
venu le temps
[Musique]
je suis resté exprès parce que j'ai une
excellente idée julie va avoir sa salade
de poisson vous allez voir
j'ai là le saladier la salade verte 1 le
sel
voilà
bon maintenant il me faut une paire de
ciseaux
voilà
voilà voilà bon je vais commencer
par
celui là la truite à
[Musique]
voile à la salade est prête et ça va
être délicieux
mets tout ce que j'aime une durée qu'il
remue de la salade
voilà
casimir qu'est ce que ça vous êtes
revenu voilà julie ta salade est prête
c'est vrai notre moi une bonne salade de
pois sont les poissons sont on pas qu
aux tu le boisseau été découpé mais oui
mais ça va être délicieux comme des
poissons en papier ça ne se mange pas
comment mais avec un peu d'imagination
c'est très très bon
ce
que j'aimais ouah
[Musique]
à